je vous propose une petite gourmandise
qui nous plonge instantanément dans
l'ambiance de Noël le pain d'épice mais
pas n'importe quel pain
[Musique]
d'épice je vous parle de celui de la
marque evvelinoise les deux gourmands
créé il y a 11 ans par deux amis leurs
produits sont composés d'ingrédients
issus du terroir francilien il propose
des biscuit du miel du chocolat et bien
sûr du pain d'épic nature ils sont
constitués à 50 % de miel de forêt issu
des massifs des ivelines et du gaâtiné
dans le centre Val-de Loire vous
retrouverez également dans leur pain
d'épic de la farine de sègle de blé du
beurre frais de la laitterie d'cini des
œufs plein air de la cannelle mais bien
sûr leur mélange secret pour le pain
d'épic gourmand et moelleux je vous le
recommande il fera sensation le jour de
Noël à votre
table